[Musik]
Hallo! Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt's mal ein spontanes Video,
nämlich ein leckeres Rezept - wie jede Woche.
Ja, aber spontan.
Deswegen, weil ich mir gedacht hab,
ich schaue jetzt einfach in den Kühlschrank,
was wir noch da haben,
was vielleicht auch noch weg muss
und wir kochen daraus etwas Spontanes.
Einfach ein leckeres Mittagessen.
Ich hätte jetzt echt gern was Leckeres, Sommerliches, Erfrischendes,
weil wir grad Hochsommer haben.
Aber das Wetter spricht leider nicht unsere Sprache.
Es ist sehr regnerisch und kalt draußen,
aber trotzdem hat man diese sommerliche Schwere in der Luft,
dieses schwüle Wetter, das einen so ein bisschen dazu bringt…
Ich will nichts Schweres essen.
Ich möchte etwas Leichtes, Leckeres, Gesundes und vor allem Schnelles.
Ich habe mir gedacht, so spontan wie ich bin…
Da hinten sitzt der Tolga; der weiß noch nichts von seinem Glück.
Tolga Möchtest du mit mir etwas kochen?
Ich wollte eigentlich dich, Jutta, fragen, aber ich weiß,
die Jutta hat gleichen Termin.
Deswegen müsstest du wahrscheinlich gleich weg.
Tolga, wollen wir zusammen was kochen?
Jetzt komm, komm, komm!
[Jutta und Sally jubeln] Ich habe eine Schürze für dich.
Das ist Tolga.
[Doing] Ja, er zieht es aus.
Ich bin auch dafür, dass wir mal einen Podcast machen, Tolga und ich.
Ja, den Podcast mit Gästen - habe ich von der Community gehört…
läuft mit mir anscheinend besser als mit Murat,
weil der Redeanteil der Gäste höher ist.
TOLGA: Hmm…
SALLY: Sagt man so.
Der Podcast mit Josh war gut.
Der Podcast mit Sarah war gut, war sehr gut.
TOLGA: Euer Podcast von… ?
SALLY: Von heute?
Darf man heute sagen? [Sally bejaht] Von heute!
Ist in der Zukunft.
TOLGA: Das war sehr interessant.
SALLY: Ja, oder?
TOLGA: Du warst sehr, sehr interessant.
SALLY: Also dann können wir auch einen Podcast machen.
Dann können wir auch erzählen, wie Tolga in unser Team kam,
wie wir uns kennengelernt haben,
denn das ist eine ganz besondere Geschichte.
Vielleicht können wir es auch so machen,
dass wir für dieses Spontanformat,
weil ich finde dieses Spontanformat irgendwie…
Spontan erfunden; jetzt haben wir ein Spontanformat.
>>Koch spontan mit Sally!<<
Irgendwie können wir es ja nennen.
Vielleicht habt ihr ja Ideen für dieses Format,
dieses Spontan-in-die Küche-stellen.
Dann schreibt doch einfach gerne eure Antwort in die Kommentare,
eure Vorschläge.
Also passt. Gehen wir erst mal Händewaschen.
TOLGA: Ja.
SALLY: 30 Sekunden einreiben,
damit sich auch alle Schmutzpartikel, Keime und Viren lösen.
So…
Schön vorbildlich!
TOLGA: Das hast du doch einmal in einem Video gezeigt. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Aber glaub es mir, ich wasch mir eher zu oft die Hän…
Ah, zu heiß und zu oft die Hände als zu wenig.
So!
Aferin, tertemiz. (Super, blitzsauber!)
Oh, mis gibi kokuyor. (Riecht hervorragend!)
Dann gehen wir mal an Kühlschrank und schauen, was der so hergibt.
TOLGA: Okay.
SALLY: Hier ist unser Vorratskühlschrank.
Gut. Ich würde sagen, auf jeden Fall etwas mit Gemüse.
Was haben wir da?
Zucchini, viel Gemüse…
Ich hätte mal wieder Lust auf Zucchini.
Angebraten oder… roh als Salat ist auch gut.
So ein bisschen Sellerie? Sellerie ist immer gut.
Sallyrie.
Die zwei sind für da und das ist zum Essen.
Möchtest du auch eins essen?
TOLGA: Danke. Nein, nein.
SALLY: Dann nehmen wir einfach mal so buntes Paprikagemüse, oder?
TOLGA: Ja, Paprika geht immer.
Das wird reichen.
SALLY: Passt.
Warte, vielleicht Käse. [Singend] Dieser Käse…
Vielleicht können wir Zoodeln machen: Zucchini, Nudel?
Mariniert?
Und daraus machen wir eine Frittata mit Eiern.
So ein Omelett.
Oberlecker!
Oh, oh!
Ich habe in München ein Eiweiß-Omelett gegessen, mit Spinat drin.
Oh, das war auch gut.
Omelett oder Frittata
- das können wir noch entscheiden.
Käse?
TOLGA: [Flüstert] Oder beides!
SALLY: [Flüstert] Beides.
Doch, dass sieht gut aus.
Dann nehmen wir noch gleich Senf für Marinade oder irgendetwas.
Aber jetzt komm, waschen wir erst einmal!
[Musik]
Ja, wir brauchen noch freshe Kreuda.
Komm Josh, ich gebe dir Schirmschutz.
[Musik]
Ich fühle mich wie Mary Poppins.
♪ Wenn ein Löffelchen voll Zucker ♪
TOLGA: Sieht schon mal gut aus, dort drüben.
SALLY: Sieht gut aus, oder?
TOLGA: Wow!
SALLY: Wow!
[Beide lachen voller Staunen]
Rausch der Unsterblichkeit.
Wow! Oh, die Tomaten.
Ok, kommt!
Was brauchen wir?
Minze brauchen wir.
Komm, Josh. Ich schütze dich.
Minze…
JOSH: Es geht schon. Ich bin nicht aus Zucker.
SALLY: Geht es? [Josh bejaht] Ok.
Was nehmen wir noch mit?
Oh, ein bisschen Liebstöckel, Maggikraut.
Liebstöckel…
Dann…
Salat können wir auch machen, aber für heute reicht es.
Oh, meine Brokkoli!
Da sind Kräuter.
[Musik]
TOLGA: Da ist eine Schnecke. [Beide lachen]
SALLY: Wo ist eine Schnecke?
TOLGA: Hier! [Lacht]
SALLY: Ach, kennt ihr die?
[Singend] Das ist Frieda, die kleine Schnecke.
Ja, ich erkenne sie an ihrer Schleimspur. [Tolga ekelt sich]
Hier!
Habe ich eigentlich ein grünes Gesicht?
JOSH: Ja, geht, aber der Ton ist so orange.
SALLY: Guck mal!
Jetzt fühlt sie ihre…
Jetzt streckt sie ihre Fühler aus.
[Tolga ekelt sich]
Hallo Frieda!
Hinterlass bitte nicht in meinem Hochbett eine Schleimspur.
Die setzen wir jetzt mal um.
Wir setzen Frieda um.
Wir nehmen ein bisschen Knoblauch mit.
Knoblauch…
Oh, Petersilie wollte ich noch, genau! Hier…
Ich habe leider nicht so viel Petersilie,
aber ich denke schon gut.
[Musik]
♪ Singing in the rain. ♪
TOLGA: ♪ It's raining men ♪
SALLY: ♪ Halleluja ♪
BEIDE: ♪ It's raining men ♪
SALLY: Den Regenschirm draußen schließen, sonst bringt es Unglück.
TOLGA: Echt? [Sally bejaht] Habe ich noch nie gehört.
SALLY: Doch, offener Regenschirm im Haus bringt Unglück.
[Musik]
Ich glaub, so sieht es ganz gut aus.
Also jetzt starten wir mit der Frittata.
Das ist praktisch wie ein Omelett. Also einfach Gemüse.
Man kann auch Fleisch nehmen, Sucuk, Wurst mit anbraten
und dann wird es schön angebraten,
es kommt eine Eiermasse drauf und dann ab in den Backofen.
Ist mal eine tolle Resteverwertung.
Wir nehmen dafür jetzt einfach 1 rote Zwiebel, 1 Knoblauchzehe,
Selleriestangen und Paprika Mix, Tomatenmark, Salz und Pfeffer,
Eier, Hirtenkäse und hier habe ich noch ein Kraut. Das ist Knoblauch.
Dann, würde ich sagen, starten wir mit Zwiebeln und Knoblauch.
Magst du Zwiebeln Knoblauch machen?
TOLGA: Yes.
SALLY: Einfach fein würfeln, vorher schälen.
Aber du kochst ja schon ab und zu auch in der Küche.
TOLGA: Ja, ich backe mehr,
aber das Kochen übernimmt dann meistens mein Mitbewohner.
SALLY: Ja schön!
Das kann ich von meinem Mitbewohner leider nicht behaupten.
Ich würfle jetzt einfach die Sellerie fein
und es wird jetzt gleich auch einfach alles zusammen angebraten.
Kennst du Frittata? Hast du das mal zubereitet?
TOLGA: Nein, ich habe es noch nie gemacht.
Ich wusste auch gar nicht, was das bedeutet.
SALLY: Ja, ich glaube viele…
Ich glaube, das verschwimmt so bisschen. Also ich würde….
Ich lehne mich jetzt weit aus dem Fenster
und würde jetzt mal behaupten,
Frittata und Omelett ist für mich so ein bisschen das Gleiche.
Meine Mutter hat nämlich immer…
Ich nehme jetzt einfach so einen Bräter.
Den kann ich auf dem Herd und im Backofen benutzen.
Meine Mutter hat für uns immer ein Kartoffelomelett gemacht:
einfach französische Kartoffeln fein gewürfelt, angebraten,
Ei drauf - fertig! Das war das beste Essen.
Meine Kinder lieben das auch.
Wir geben einfach das gewürfelte Gemüse mit Olivenöl in die Pfanne.
Oh, wir hätten wieder die Tipps ausprobieren sollen.
Ich habe die Zunge draußen, aber ich glaube, es war zu spät.
[Beide lachen]
Der Tolga war, wie gesagt, vorher bei uns in Mannheim im Shop,
dort im Verkauf usw. …
Und davor warst du bei Zara, richtig?
TOLGA: Ja, davor war ich bei Zara.
SALLY: Da war ich in der Herrenabteilung zuständig für die Kollektion.
Oh!
TOLGA: Und jetzt hier was ganz Anderes, aber es macht super viel Spaß.
SALLY: Ja, ich würde sagen, den größten Teil unserer Kennenlerngeschichte…
den packen wir im Podcast aus.
Das machen wir
und den machen wir direkt für morgen.
Also wenn heute das Video kommt, ist morgen der Podcast.
TOLGA: Okay.
SALLY: Etwas Passenderes gibt es ja nicht. [Lacht]
TOLGA: Knoblauch kann ich ja pressen, oder?
SALLY: Ja. Komm, den pressen wir!
Guck mal, bei der Paprika schneide ich immer so Deckel und Boden weg,
sodass am wenigsten Müll entsteht.
Zack, den Strunk hier weg
und dann im Prinzip einfach nur die Seiten wegschneiden.
Dann hat man die Paprika ohne Abfall
- im Prinzip nur das aus der Mitte -
schön entkernt.
[Musik]
Oh!
[Beide lachen]
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das trifft sich gerade ganz gut.
Ariane kam in die Küche und ich wollte gerade sagen:
Ariane, willst du auch mal mit mir kochen?
In dem Moment spritzt der Tolga mit seinem Knoblauch durch die Küche.
TOLGA: Es tut mir leid.
SALLY: Oh Gott, du Arme.
Jetzt riecht sie, als hätte sie in einer Dönerbude gearbeitet.
Oh nein!
Brauchst du ein Tuch?
Der ganze Kühlschrank ist voll.
Komm Ariane, zeig dich mal! Stell dich mal vor!
Das ist Ariane.
Ariane wird auch mal bestimmt… Willst du mal mit mir kochen?
ARIANE: Oder backen, lieber backen.
[Sally flüstert etwas zu, beide lachen]
SALLY: Wir können auch etwas backen, okay.
Wir haben ein neues Format.
Oh, macht ihr kurz Sarah die Tür auf? Sie steht im Regen. [Lacht]
Wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt: "Was ist heute bei der Sally los?"
Es ist jeden Tag so.
Die übrigen Tage oder in den anderen Videos verstecke ich es nur immer,
Aber jeden Tag geht es hier so zu.
Jemand geht rein, einer geht raus, der andere spritzt mit Knoblauch.
Okay. Essen ist auch bei uns gleich fertig.
Also wir schneiden noch kurz das Gemüse fertig und braten es hier an.
TOLGA: Die Eier kann ich schon trennen?
SALLY: Ja, die Eier können wir schon einmal in eine Schüssel geben.
[Musik]
So, das Gemüse braten wir jetzt einfach so ein bisschen an,
bei mittelhoher Hitze.
Ariane hat kurz Knoblauchspuren beseitigt.
TOLGA: [Doing] Es war aus Versehen.
SALLY: Ja, es war aus Versehen.
Mein Gott, das machen wir nicht mit Absicht hier.
- Menschen mit Knoblauch beschmeißen.
Ich finde, es ist auch so ein Gericht,
was man so schön in Gesellschaft kochen kann;
weißt du, einfach Gemüse usw.
Der Tolga hat jetzt auch schon den Käse gewürfelt.
Ja, und was machen wir dann noch?
Genau, den Knobloch.
Das ist der Knobloch.
Das ist praktisch sowas wie Schnittlauch, nur riecht es nach Knoblauch.
TOLGA: Ich habe es gerade gemerkt.
SALLY: Ein bisschen doppelt gemoppelt,
weil wir jetzt auch Knoblauch drin haben, aber ist ja egal.
Ich wollte nur einmal etwas Anderes an Gewürzen und Kräutern zeigen.
Das Gemüse braten wir jetzt einfach schön an,
damit es Röstaromen bekommt und dann wird es gleich richtig lecker.
Du kannst auch schon einmal die Eier mit Salz und Pfeffer würzen.
Und ich glaube, das Tomatenmark würde ich auch zu den Eiern geben,
Dann haben wir da so eine schöne Farbe mit dabei.
Isst du eigentlich abends noch etwas, wenn du heimgehst?
TOLGA: Ich sag mal so:
Wenn wir jetzt bisschen später essen als sonst, dann ja.
aber meistens nur Obst.
Ja, eher so Obst.
SALLY: Hier bei uns im Büro ist es so:
Wer mit mir hier unten arbeitet, da ist es schon so,
dass wir so ein bisschen unregelmäßig eine Pause haben.
Josh lacht.
Also ich sage es mal so,
der Rest vom Team isst immer um 12 oder 13 Uhr - zur Mittagszeit.
Und bei uns ist es immer so, je nachdem, wie der Dreh läuft.
Dann haben wir mal vielleicht um 13 Uhr eine Pause,
aber mal auch um 17 Uhr.
Ja, wir essen öfter mal um 16 oder 17 Uhr.
TOLGA: Die Zeit vergeht aber auch so schnell.
Dann realisiert man das auch gar nicht.
SALLY: Ja, bei mir ist es auch das Problem…
Das jetzt z.B. - ich könnte es jetzt nicht kochen,
wenn ich jetzt satt wäre.
Dann kann ich sowas nicht kochen.
Und der Josh hinter der Kamera:
"Ja, gib mir Essen, gib mir einfach Essen!" [Josh lacht und stimmt zu]
Aber deswegen haben wir jetzt auch heute die Region wieder unterstützt
und haben etwas hier von einem türkischen Spezialitätenladen bestellt,
damit wir das gleich essen können,
während das hier alles noch ruht und Fotos gemacht werden müssen.
Sonst haben wir wieder so um 18 Uhr Essen.
TOLGA: Das kriegt dann heute Abend der Murat, oder?
SALLY: Genau, das ist für heute Abend für uns.
[Musik]
D.h., wir braten hier einfach nur kurzes Gemüse an,
so ungefähr insgesamt 10 Minuten.
Du hast ja schon… Was hast du gemacht?
TOLGA: Eier, Salz, Pfeffer und Tomatenmark mit rein.
SALLY: Genau, da können wir noch den Knoblauch dazu geben
und dann kann das hier ruhen.
und wir räumen hier kurz auf und kümmern uns gleich um den Salat.
Bevor wir jetzt die Frittata weitermachen:
Wir haben heute noch einen Gast da.
Das Video ist ein bisschen durcheinander, spontan,
aber komm her! Wir sind doch spontan.
[Jubel]
PHILIP: Hello!
SALLY: Philip ist da.
PHILIP: Hallo zusammen.
Ich habe euch was mitgebracht.
SALLY: Zeig mal!
PHILIP: Bunte Köstlichkeiten zum Verfeinern.
SALLY: Oh, saure Drachenzungen!
PHILIP: Alles dabei.
SALLY: Blaue Drachen.
TOLGA: Spinnenbeine.
PHILIP: Hitschies.
SALLY: Was wurde eigentlich aus unserer Aktion letztes Mal?
Was wurde da draus?
PHILIP: Und zwar heute vor einem Jahr,
ich glaube, es war heute vor einem Jahr,
standen wir hier und wir haben euch gefragt:
Wie nennen wir unser neues Produkt bzw. …
Ihr wisst ja, es hieß damals Volles Rohr.
Und da haben wir überlegt…
Weil wir ja Drachenzungen, Spinnenbeine haben.
Und was würde dazu besser passen als Saure Krakenarme?
SALLY: Das war ein Zuschauervorschlag, oder?
PHILIP: Ich glaube schon.
Ich muss noch genau reingucken, aber ich glaube schon.
Richtig, richtig cool!
SALLY: Ach wie schön.
Es ist so schön, dass unser Candyman wieder da ist.
PHILIP: Das Miteinander!
Und was heißt das?
Das heißt…
[Sarah spielt das Lied "Candyman" ab; alle lachen]
SARAH: Was ist das für eine Version?
ALLE: ♪ Sweet, sugar, candy man. ♪
[Verschiedene Töne]
♪ I met him out for dinner on a Friday night ♪
♪ He really got me working up an appetite ♪
♪ He had tattoos up and down his arm ♪
♪ There's nothing more dangerous than a boy with charm ♪
♪ He's a one stop shop, makes the panties drop ♪
♪ He's a sweet talkin' sugar coated candy man ♪
♪ A sweet talkin' sugar coated candy man ♪
[Musik]
SALLY: Ich glaube, den Text müssen wir noch ein bisschen üben.
Der ist sehr schnell.
PHILIP: Also hier ist alles drin.
SALLY: Sweet Sugar Candy Man
Sarah saß da übrigens seit letztem Sommer
und hat auf ihren zweiten Einsatz gewartet.
PHILIP: Du hast das hervorragend gemacht.
[Jubel und Applaus]
So, ich lasse eure bunten Köstlichkeiten…
SALLY: Eigentlich könntet ihr den Text, den Candy Man,
könntet ihr auf Hitschies umschreiben.
PHILIP: Auch ganz witzig.
SALLY: Ich kenne da so zwei Texterinnen,
die gerne mal Songs umtexten,
PHILIP: Das wäre eigentlich ganz witzig.
JOSH: Wir produzieren auch Musikvideos.
SALLY: Wir produzieren auch Musikvideos
PHILIP: Ich zeige ihnen gleich mal was. Wait and see.
Euch viel Spaß beim…
SALLY: Dann statten wir das Büro aus.
PHILIP: Backen. Genau, stattet das Büro aus.
Ich verbringe jetzt meine Zeit mit Murat.
Der wartet auch schon auf mich.
SALLY: Der freut sich.
PHILIP: Viel Spaß. Sieht sehr, sehr lecker aus. Es duftet…
SALLY: Wir machen Frittata. Dann könnt ihr zum Essen kommen.
PHILIP: Wir freuen uns aufs Essen.
Die lege ich mal hier hin der daneben oder wo auch immer. Tschüss!
SALLY: Eigentlich wäre es witzig, wir essen so eine blaue Drachenzunge.
Einfach probieren, einfach probieren!
Ach komm, wir machen blau.
TOLGA: Oder die Krabben.
SALLY: Oh, die Krabbenbeine! Komm, wir probieren die Krabben.
SARAH: Krake.
PHILIP: Beide!
SALLY: Krake! Krakenarme!
PHILIP: Blaue Drachenzunge.
Es macht ganz viel blaue Zunge.
TOLGA: Das ist übrigens…
SALLY: Es gibt glaub ich so drei Arten von Menschen, wie sie die Tüte öffnen.
PHILIP: Okay.
SALLY: Du hast so abgerissen. Ich so!
Und dann gibt's noch die Aufschneider.
PHILIP: Es gibt auch die Profis, die aufreißen und dann fällt alles unten raus.
SALLY: Wäre auch so ein TikTok…
ALLE: Mmh! Mmh!
TOLGA: Was ist heute los?
[Alle lachen[
SALLY: Eigentlich fehlt jetzt noch Murat und Jan.
Und die machen die Zunge blau? [Philip bejaht]
PHILIP: So lecker.
SALLY: Kennt ihr das, wenn euch schon das Wasser im Mund zusammenläuft,
immer bevor man es gegessen hat?
PHILIP: Was sagst du?
TOLGA: Mega, aber das ist noch, noch geiler!
PHILIP: Noch megara?
TOLGA: Noch Megara, noch geiler.
Darf ich das sagen? [Sally bejaht]
Mega, mega!
Ist meine Zunge blau?
SALLY: Zeig! Lila…
PHILIP: Lecker?
SALLY: Vegan, oder?
PHILIP: Vegan! Einfach lecker.
Zum Backen, Kochen und alles.
TOLGA: So eine Torte will ich!
SALLY: Damit eine Ganache.
Das färbt sich ja dann auch dadurch.
PHILIP: Aber was haut noch einmal komplett durch?
Also ja.
Hast du eine?
Weiter raus! Da kommt sie. [Lacht]
SALLY: Das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Das Abendprogramm.
Also nicht bei uns! [Alle lachen]
Ciao Philip! [Philip lacht]
PHILIP: Tschüss zusammen!
SALLY: Wir machen mal lieber die Frittata weiter.
Wieder zurück zur Seriosität.
Das Gemüse ist angebraten.
Wartet… heiß, heiß, heiß.
Dann kannst du da ja die Eiermasse drüber gießen
und dann noch einmal den Käse drauf.
Den Ofen habe ich schon auf 170°C Ober-/Unterhitze vorgeheizt.
und das backt dann 20 Min.
Und in derzeit können wir die Zucchini-Nudeln zubereiten.
Oder? [Tolga stimmt zu] Passt!
So ein bisschen schaukeln.
Dann verteilt es sich gut. Jetzt noch Käse drauf.
Darfst du auch machen.
Das sieht doch gut aus.
Da könnt ihr echt alles mit hinein geben,
was euch gut schmeckt.
Ich glaube, ich lasse aus diesem Rezept die Liebstöckel doch weg,
weil mir das irgendwie nicht so dazu passt.
Schön.
Gut, ab in den Ofen!
Wir machen kurz sauber und kümmern uns dann um die Zucchini-Nudeln.
[Musik]
[Uhr]
Komm, jetzt darfst du moderieren.
Du hast mir oft genug zugeguckt!
TOLGA: Boah, jetzt bin ich gerade voll überfordert. Warte!
Was tun wir jetzt?
Als Nächstes bereiten wir die Zucchini vor.
SALLY: Ja, machen wir den Zucchini-Salat.
Und das wollen wir als Zucchini-Nudeln machen,
aber roh, also nicht anbraten.
Ihr könnt sie auch anbraten,
aber ich finde Rohkost eigentlich immer ganz gut.
Wir nehmen die Minze und die Petersilie, die Zucchini, Olivenöl,
Limettensaft, Walnuss, Kerne und Salz und Pfeffer.
Und wenn es uns noch nicht schmeckt,
nehmen wir noch paar Zutaten dazu.
TOLGA: Vom Garten. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Also bei der Zucchini haben wir jetzt gedacht, wir machen Spiralen.
Und zwar haben wir so einen Spiralschneider.
Ich finde den eigentlich ganz witzig.
Man muss nur immer wegen der Länge gucken.
Und zwar baut man den so zusammen…
Im Prinzip das da rein
und dann da oben den Griff.
TOLGA: Von links ist es so komisch.
SALLY: Ja, links, wenn man Rechtshänder ist.
Und das hier ist der Auffangbehälter.
Dann kann man da nämlich verschiedene Stärken einstellen.
Das würde ich jetzt einfach dir übergeben.
Einfach Zucchini rein.
TOLGA: Jetzt in die Mitte?
SALLY: Genau! Dann so einmal festdrücken,
dass die praktisch fixiert ist und dann mit bisschen Druck drehen.
Dann entstehen Zucchini-Nudeln.
Man muss im Prinzip einfach nur aufpassen,
dass man die Zucchini so hoch schneidet wie die Box hier ist.
Also diese Höhe an Gemüse kann rein.
Das kann man mit einem Apfel machen oder mit ganz anderem
- Zwiebeln, Rote Beete… mit allem Möglichen.
Das Einzige, was dann übrig bleibt, ist das, aber das macht ja nichts.
Können wir so naschen. [Tolga stimmt zu]
Dann haben wir die Spaghetti.
Cool, gell?
Man kann es auch direkt in die Schüssel machen.
Das können wir auch.
Das ist so ein kleiner Auffangbehälter.
Man kann sich hier, aber…
TOLGA: Aber es ist halt…
SALLY: Ja, ich finde es so ganz praktisch.
Dann gebe ich dir das
und ich werde einfach schon einmal die Kräuter hacken.
Wir sind schon immer so, dass wir mittags hier schon gesund essen.
TOLGA: Ja, immer!
SALLY: Wenn wir selbst kochen.
TOLGA: Also du und Sarah auf jeden Fall. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Die anderen so…
TOLGA: Darf ich es sagen? [Sally bejaht]
Die von oben… [Sally lacht]
Wenn wir oben sind, dann gibt's meistens Nudeln.
SALLY: Aber…
TOLGA: Wenn wir nicht warten können, bis du mit dem Kochen fertig bist.
SALLY: Ja, das stimmt.
Aber wenn z.B. Benni kocht, ist auch gesund. [Tolga stimmt zu]
Vegan und gesund und Gemüse.
Und hier kocht immer mal irgendjemand. Also nicht immer nur ich.
TOLGA: Mal gibt's unten Essen, mal gibt's oben Essen. [Sally stimmt zu]
Aber auf jeden Fall immer für jeden etwas dabei.
SALLY: Auf jeden Fall.
Murat meckert immer, wenn es zu viel Gemüse ist.
[Musik]
Soll, hier noch ein bisschen Olivenöl rein.
Ich gebe jetzt auch einfach schon einmal alle Zutaten dazu,
TOLGA: die Kräuter
SALLY: und Limettensaft.
Ich bin zu langsam.
Nein, bist du nicht.
Wir sind ein Team. Wir arbeiten gut.
[Musik]
Dann noch die Walnüsse grob hacken
und dann würzen wir es mit Salz und Pfeffer.
[Musik]
Und dann…
Also ich will es nur ungern sagen,
aber man hätte auch eine größere Schüssel nehmen können.
TOLGA: Vielleicht.
SALLY: Maybe…
Und alles verrühren.
[Musik]
TOLGA: Willst du weitermachen?
SALLY: Yes! Es geht relativ einfach mit dem… Spiralschneider?
Spiralschneider!
Da kann man so verschiedene Dicken und Scheiben aufmachen.
Also schon nicht so schlecht.
Und dann kann der hier jetzt nämlich schön durchziehen.
Die Frittata backt im Ofen fertig.
Wir räumen auf und dann haben wir echt so ein schnelles…
- Was war das jetzt? -
… 30 Minuten-Gericht.
TOLGA: Kürzer sogar.
SALLY: Kürzer, oder? [Tolga bejaht]
20 Min. sind es im Ofen.
TOLGA: Aber ja, wir haben es zu zweit gemacht.
SALLY: Ja, wenn man das allein macht,
so mit allem - passt!
[Musik]
Jetzt kann probiert werden.
Also war ja doch echt ein cooles, schnelles Gericht.
TOLGA: Ja, perfekt für Resteverwertung. [Sally stimmt zu]
So!
SALLY: Ich habe den gar nicht abgeschmeckt.
Du? Auch nicht…
Wir haben den gar nicht probiert.
Ach, das passt schon.
Das wird immer gut sein, wenn du es machst.
Aww! Wir haben es gemeinsam zubereitet.
Gut, wenn er so ein bisschen durchzieht, dann werden die Nudeln…
Dann werden sie schön geschmeidig und weich.
Ich sehe es schon kommen,
Jetzt ist gleich der ganze Teller leer auf einer Gabel.
[Beide lachen]
Als wären das Glasnudeln wie beim Asiaten.
Oh Gott!
[Beide lachen]
Okay, so eine Unendlich-Zucchini.
Ah!
TOLGA: Da hört es auf.
SALLY: Ich probiere hier so eine Ecke.
Eigentlich müsste Philip noch probieren. [Tolga stimmt zu]
PHILIP: Hey, habt ihr noch eine Gabel?
SALLY: Bisschen Salz hat gefehlt.
TOLGA: Ich war etwas sparsam.
SALLY: Vielleicht habe ich die Zucchini versalzen.
PHILIP: Ist etwas lang.
Ach Quatsch!
SALLY: Jetzt können wir so Susi und Strolch… [Alle lachen]
Jeder an einem Ende in der Küche.
PHILIP: Mmh!
Siehst du? Susi und Strolch.
Lecker.
SALLY: Dieses Gericht isst man mit Schere und Gabel.
PHILIP: Richtig lecker.
TOLGA: Perfekt für Pärchen.
PHILIP: Romantisches Dinner, Candle-Light-Dinner - sehr lecker!
SALLY: Zu dritt.
PHILIP: Ja, das ist super. [Sally und Philip lachen]
TOLGA: Der ist superfrisch. [Sally und Philip stimmen zu]
PHILIP: Richtig gut.
Aber was ist die Frische? Zitrone?
SALLY: Limette?
PHILIP: Ja, richtig lecker.
SALLY: Und er ist nicht versalzen.
PHILIP: Das riecht gut. Top und lecker!
SALLY: Die lachen immer drüber, wie ich salze.
PHILIP: Nein, gehört doch dazu. [Sally stimmt zu]
Wie Zucker - Geschmacksträger.
Top.
SALLY: Schnelles, spontanes Gericht.
PHILIP: Sehr, sehr lecker. Tschüss!
SALLY: Dann wünschen wir euch viel Spaß. [Alle lachen[
Kurz und schmerzlos.
Wir wünschen euch viel Spaß beim Nachmachen.
Wünscht euch gern ein Teammitglied von mir in die Küche
und auch gern Rezeptvorschläge.
Also wenn ihr z.B. sagt, mach mal mit Sarah eine dreistöckige Motivtorte,
dann mach ich das natürlich.
Aber dann ist spontan ein bisschen schwierig,
denn dann brauchen wir ein paar Tage. [Alle lachen]
Also schreibt uns gern, ob euch das Format gefallen hat
und ob wir so weitermachen sollen
und dann machen wir das gern für euch.
PHILIP: Bis zum nächsten Mal.
ALLE: Tschüss!
Rezept gibt's wie immer in der Sallys-App.
SALLY: So, jetzt haben wir aber alle einen Riesenhunger.
PHILIP: Richtig lecker!
SALLY: Jetzt gehen wir an den Tisch. [Lacht]
PHILIP: Das ist das Abendessen. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Das ist schon auch ein bisschen Low Carb,
PHILIP: Alles vegan.
SALLY: Ja, vegetarisch auf jeden Fall.
Ohne Ei wäre es auch vegan,
aber dann wäre es auch keine Frittata. [Lacht]
Ja, das sind die Hitschie-Schnüre.
PHILIP: Mmh!
SALLY: Das nehmen wir jetzt einmal mit.
[Musik]